[MUSIC PLAYING]
Happy Thursday, everybody.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
I hope that everybody's
having a great week.
I'm having an awesome week.
We are in Palm Springs,
California for our work week.
So the whole-- well,
most of the Posit company
is all out here just working
together and just getting
to do fun things with each other
because we don't see each other
all the time.
But if this is your
first time joining us
at the Data Science Hangout,
so nice to meet you.
I'm Rachael.
This is an open space to chat
about data science leadership,
questions you're
facing, and getting
to hear about what's going
on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so, every week we feature
a different data science leader
as my co-host to help
lead our discussion
and answer questions
from you all.
So together we're all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
And we love when we
can hear from everyone,
no matter your background, level
of experience, or area of work.
It is totally OK
to just listen in.
I was actually just telling
this to some of my coworkers
as well.
But there's also three ways you
can ask questions and provide
your own perspective
on certain topics too.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You could also put
questions in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you wanted me to read
it out loud instead.
And then we also
have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And then if this isn't shared
in the chat right away,
I'll put it there in a second.
We do share the
recordings of each session
up to our Posit YouTube
and our Hangout website.
So you can always go back and
rewatch or share with friends.
One added note I just
wanted to throw out here.
If you are hiring, feel free
to share that in the chat.
I never see that as
spammy or anything.
You want to share any
open positions there,
feel free to put them there.
But with all that, I'm
so excited to be joined
by my co-host, Emi
Zambada, Assistant Vice
President of Annuity
Distribution Intelligence
at Nationwide Financial.
Emi, thanks so much
for joining us.
I'd love to have you just start
by introducing yourself, maybe
a little about your
role, and something
you like to do outside of work.
Thank you.
Thanks, Rachael.
And definitely jealous because
you are in Palm Springs.
I'm here in freezing
Columbus, Ohio with some snow.
So definitely I wish
I were over there.
But very happy to be
here with all of you.
And I appreciate the time.
And as you say, Emi Zambada.
I work for Nationwide, not
the property and casualty,
the [INAUDIBLE].
We work in the financial
services, specifically
in annuity.
I've been in the company
for over four years.
I've been all over the place,
working for Whirlpool, Siemens.
I started my career or
education in accounting.
But life takes you to places.
And now, I lead what we call the
distribution intelligence team.
That is nothing else but using
technology and data analytics
to support our sales teams to
be more effective and efficient.
So again, thanks
for having me here.
Thanks for joining us.
And what's something you
like to do outside of work?
I like reading.
I like to have a beer.
I go with cheap beer, Bud Light.
I like sports.
And I have a little boy.
And I spend a lot of time
with my wife and the kid.
So yeah.
And not a lot of free time,
but whenever I can, definitely
like to travel, go
places, visit Mexico.
I'm originally from Mexico.
That's great.
So Emi, I know when we
were speaking briefly
before the Hangout, you
mentioned a lot about people's
development on your
team and how you get joy
out of helping people develop.
And I thought that
would be a fun
place to going to kick
off the conversation
and just learn a little
bit more about how
you do that with your team.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, definitely passionate
about personal development,
helping people
with their careers.
At Nationwide, we have over
100, 150 data scientists,
over 200 data engineers,
or data-related roles.
So it's a big group.
And this is known in
the data science space,
people are mostly introverts.
They like to be
heads down, coding,
and they do amazing things.
But one thing that nobody--
not really good at is thinking
about their career, building
a personal brand,
networking, things
that are really important
as you build your career
and you have aspirations
to become a future leader.
So and I'm naturally
an introvert,
but probably push
myself to be out there
and building relationships.
So I always tell people
that it's very important,
get the work done,
get the results.
Results are what matter.
But also, it's important
to be out there,
build these meaningful
relationship, networks.
And don't be shy about
connecting with people.
You never know, you
will make a new friend,
you will get into
a new partnership,
a new whatever that might be.
One thing I want to acknowledge
here, and before we continue,
Rachael, this--
I don't want to ignore the
situation that happening right
now in America with Tyler
Nichols and the not very
good news happening with
the Black community.
So I want to make sure
that we acknowledge that.
We support them.
One thing that we do, I
feel very well at Nationwide
is that diversity and inclusion.
So helping people from
all different backgrounds,
ethnicity, and races.
So I want to make
sure that we all
acknowledge the situation
that is happening
and support organizations
that help those groups.
So I'm wearing here my
hoodie from Latinx and AI.
I'm a big fan of
that organization.
I try to help them as a Latino.
But then, I want to make sure
that if you have the means,
anything can help, by being a
mentor, financially supporting.
There's a lot of groups like
a woman in AI, Black in AI,
AI For All, you name it.
So go out there,
support those groups.
I think, and do whatever you
can to support that community.
Absolutely.
Thank you for that, Emi.
And if you have some
links, I know you just
mentioned a few groups too.
But if anybody wants to share
some of those links in the chat
so that we all have them here
too, that would be great.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I see we're starting to get a
few questions in from the chat.
And Jared, I see
you just asked one.
Do you want to jump in?
I see you unmuted, but
I can't hear you yet.
So I can ask it.
I can see the question,
so I can just read it.
It's OK.
I'll read it.
But the question was with
buzzwords like ChatGPT,
has AI impacted your
workflow as of now?
Yeah.
Specifically with
the ChatGPT, we
started using in a
limited way, to be frank.
There's a lot of great
stuff about that technology
and that tool specifically.
There's a lot of things
that we need to make sure,
like privacy,
security, making sure
that it's used
appropriately, and we
don't raise the-- or data,
or secret sauce, the code.
So we have used it like we use
Google, and Stack Overflow,
and the many other tools
that are out there.
So I want to make
sure that-- or we
want to make sure that
we do it in a meaningful
but educated way.
So we've been trying to--
we released some statements
about what is it, how
to use it, where not to use it.
And but definitely evaluating
what is coming in the future.
I think there is a--
AI in general has impacted
your workflow absolutely.
We started doing AI
and machine learning
models over 10 years ago.
Like probably a lot
of the big companies,
we have a lot of
models in production
provided producing results.
We have a patented
model factor in play
when we have all the
AI models implemented.
So there are many,
many different ways
that we use them from
underwriting, pricing, claims,
acquisition, you name it.
So we can always get
into any specific detail.
But definitely it's one of
the many ways we use it.
Thank you.
I just wanted to
remind everybody,
we shared the Slido
link in the chat
too if you wanted to ask
questions anonymously.
But if you just joined,
feel free to just raise
your hand on Zoom or you can
use the Zoom chat as well.
But something I also
wanted to ask you about,
Emi, is in the Hangouts we
talk a lot about communication
across the business.
And I know this is something
that you focus a lot on,
bridging the gap between data
science and the business.
And I'm curious if you have
any tips for all of us.
Yeah.
Big part of my role now, and
I'm fairly new in the role,
like three months.
But even my previous role, I was
leading the advanced analytics
team, that was kind
of the translators
in between the business
and the data scientist.
And even now, I'm as
a data intelligence,
I'm in between sales
people and data scientists
or business intelligence team.
I think one thing that is
really, really important
is understanding the
business, understanding
the people using the different
technology that we have.
And I will split it in two ways.
So one is the leaders.
And the other one is the
frontline associate, so
people in the field.
So you need to understand both.
You need to make sure that
both are agree with whatever
you plan to build.
And let me start
with the leader.
So definitely, you need them.
Cannot ignore what they want.
They know about the strategy.
They have the funding.
Money is very important.
So without money, it's very
hard to do anything else.
So make sure that
you understand where
they want to go, what
are you planning to do.
What are the
challenges they face?
What are the things that
they want to achieve?
And ask questions, and get
to know them personally.
I think that helps, get
closer to their heart.
And but then explain what
you do and how it works.
But knowing that they
don't live in our world.
And they don't want to learn
all the stuff that we know,
because they don't
have the time,
and their focus is to run the
business, not to understand
AI and data analytics.
But knowing what
is enough so they
can get a good
sense of what we do,
and they can relate
and think about how
that can be used for the work
that they want to be done.
So again, not to
be a brown nose,
like it's said of
them, but really
important to know them and
get to understand them.
And then, you have the frontline
people, like sale people,
call center, whomever is
going to use the technology
that you have.
Make the things easier for them.
Don't build something
then say, well, they
need to figure
out how to use it.
Because they're not
going to use it.
They are busy.
They have a lot to do.
They have a very time
matrix, whatever else--
whatever that is,
like a sales goals,
call they need to
handle, whatever
that might be the case.
So you need to make it very
easy so that doesn't drastically
change the work they do.
Think about Netflix.
When you watch Netflix and
you have recommendations,
you just watch TV
and you just get
the different recommendations,
and you just select that.
So you don't need to know
what is going on there,
or you don't need to
understand the algorithm,
or change the way you watch TV.
It's just a helpful tool.
So for our sale people,
we tend to make mistakes.
We give them a lot
of information,
a lot of data points,
a lot of dashboards,
and we overwhelm them.
And then they get
to a point that they
don't know where to find it.
They don't have the
time to look at it.
They get-- there's
too many data points
that they get this phrase
with all these dashboards
and situations there.
So we need to be,
instead of giving them
a lot of dashboards and cool
visualizations and things
that they might not even look
at it, because, again, they
get overwhelmed, tell
them what is the actual.
Who they need to
contact and why.
And tell them what to do next.
So they start the day
and say, all right,
what do I need to do?
OK, you've got to
call these people.
And you're going
to talk about this.
And you are going to
then do these activities.
And a little bit of why helps
in simple English definitely.
Don't build in procedure,
and inaccuracy,
and anything like that, or
don't share those things.
But then, but you need
to build the trust.
For example, things
that are ways
to erode the trust if you tell
them, hey, contact this person,
and the phone number is wrong.
Or contact this
person and the person
is no longer working
for that company.
Or hey, do this, and they
try it, and they try it,
and that doesn't work.
You're going to lose that trust.
And that's definitely not good.
So make sure your data is good.
You tell, you validate some
of the things you are sharing.
And ask for feedback.
People forgive if you give
them something that didn't work
or the data wasn't good, but if
you are arrogant and you say,
but you got to use it.
And I'm sure what
I gave you is good,
they're just going to
ignore it in the future.
So again, start
with your leaders.
Understand them.
Get closer to them
personally, professionally.
And then, but don't lose
the focus on the end user.
Thank you.
And when you say don't
overwhelm them with dashboards,
how are you serving that
information to them?
So the dashboard, I see one
of the comments by dashboard.
Yeah, I think there's nothing
wrong about having dashboard.
The problem is that
you need to share
with them what is really
meaningful for the work
that they do.
Keep it simple.
And if they want
to get more detail,
probably have a way that
they get drill into details.
And be specific on
what they need to do.
If you say, hey,
here is a dashboard.
And you can see how much they
sell, and the opportunities,
and what can be next.
But be very clear
of what is the--
you are asking for the
ask, or the expectation.
Hey, you want to start
talking from here to here.
And this is why.
And this is some data
points that might help you
with your conversation.
So keep it simple like that.
And if they want to
explore more, and give them
the opportunity to explore more.
So people still like to get that
in Excel, and play with that.
So it's OK.
But be specific, and don't
make it to a black box
that they don't understand
what's going on and why.
Marlene, I see you
asked a great question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in?
I actually think--
I mean, and you actually
answered it already.
But I was just curious--
really, I struggle with the
c-suite in my organization.
I can give them
flashy, because flashy
feels like it's new age,
and bright and shiny,
and look at what the 21st
century can bring you.
But you try to drill
in, here's the take-away
from what you're looking at.
The only problem is,
I have severe anxiety
about live demos.
So I was just curious, do
you prefer live demos maybe?
Or that question was way
more open-ended than what
I'm getting into.
But that was the idea.
Something vivid and
moving, or do you
prefer static and something
that they could just
stare at and take in,
and really get everything
that's on the screen?
Yeah.
And great question.
And I don't think
there's a magic formula.
But I will tell you
that the higher you
go in the organization, the more
you behave like a little kid.
The attention span
is very limited.
They have so many
things going on,
so much stuff that
they need to handle,
that if you put a
lot of things, or you
try to demonstrate them very
complicated, you lose them,
and it's very hard to get them
back-- their attention back
to what you want them to do.
So a little kid, you
play with the little kid,
and they get bored,
and they move on.
They do something else.
And you say, no, no, no, but
here is this or that toy.
And they're like, ah,
they're on something else.
So I think it's a little
bit behave like that.
So you need to be, hey,
what they really care?
What is in their mind?
What is the things that
they are worried now?
They want to increase sales
in a specific product.
They want to reach a new market.
They want to target a
new channel, whatever
that might be.
Or they want to reduce number of
calls, whatever that might be.
And be a-- start high-level.
Like, hey, you want to do this.
I see this in the data.
And you follow, and maybe asking
questions, or look at them.
Like either it is in person,
now with the video conference,
hopefully they are on camera.
You can tell, are they nodding?
Are they distracted?
They go from camera,
you lost them.
So be mindful about
reading the people,
not only what they
said, but what
they do with their expression.
So keep an eye on that.
And as you talk about, and
again, start high level.
Don't worry about
the technology.
Don't worry about the--
don't talk about the tool.
Don't talk about how you
made the [INAUDIBLE]..
But keep it something
that they care.
And I think, hopefully,
if you engage them,
they're going to start asking
more specific questions.
Live demos, to your specific
question about live demos,
live demos are dangerous.
So if you have a--
PowerPoints are still rolling
most of the companies.
So if you get a screenshot,
and you put it there,
and that's something
that you prove it works.
And know what you're
presenting very well.
So get a very good example.
Get a very good dashboard.
Get to know the
dashboard very well.
Because if they ask you
something about that,
how you calculated this, or
how you come up with this,
or tell me more
about that example,
you don't know that
very well, you're
going to lose that
trust, and the perception
will change about
the work that you do.
And probably, lastly
I will say, be your--
like the [INAUDIBLE].
What are the things that
they're going to challenge me?
What are the things that can go
wrong about this presentation?
What are the things
that they might not
like about what I'm presenting?
I'm sure they're not
going to like this.
How am I going to convince
them to like this?
So don't prepare for the
best possible scenario.
Prepare for the worst
scenario, and that
will get you ready for
if some of that happened,
or all of that happened.
So I don't know if that helped.
That was very helpful.
Thank you so much.
EMI ZAMBADA: Yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Wanted to jump over
to a few questions
that were on Slido.
And so one was, what type
of data do you work with?
Where does the data come from?
And I guess this is a few
questions [LAUGHS] in one.
And also, what tools do your
300-plus people work with?
Excel, Python, R,
SAS, in what mix?
Yeah.
Like probably any other
big older organization,
we're almost 100
years in business.
So we have in different
business units.
So we have so many data
sources, so many legacy systems.
So data is all over
the place, different--
excuse me-- different
quality, different shape,
different format,
different databases.
So definitely, it's a challenge.
We try to consolidate and merit
a lot of those data points.
We have data legs.
We have data stores, and
data model, you name it.
So I would like to say,
oh, yeah, we nailed it.
We know all the data
thing, and it's perfect.
So definitely, it's
a big challenge.
Data engineers are
way underestimated--
I think, that we
don't have many.
We probably need
more and better.
We have great people,
don't get me wrong.
But definitely, it's a very,
very much needed profession.
And if you are into data
engineering, you got it.
That's a great place to be.
We use a lot of structured
data from a honor system,
like reports reports,
and transactional data,
and things like that.
But we also use a lot of
unstructured data, like calls,
texts, emails, a lot
of third party data.
We have quite a lot of
information about the market,
about the customers.
So definitely a lot
of temporary data,
and trying to combine
with the internal data.
So in terms of tools,
a lot of Python,
R, still a lot of Excel.
Probably something we are
evolving, but still very
popular out there.
A lot of Tableau.
We started more with Power BI.
In terms of databases,
there's Snowflakes, a lot of--
we're big AWS job, so S3
bucket, and [INAUDIBLE] maker.
So I tried to narrow
the number of tools
that are used to make
it easier for the team,
but still different data bricks,
different tools out there.
We try to-- we're big into open
source tools like Python and R
and things like that as part.
But still, we use a lot
of commercial tools.
We used to do a lot of
SAS, no longer a SAS job.
But yeah.
I hope that helped.
Thank you.
I see some feedback
in the chat, that--
[LAUGHS] Javier
said, if Emi decides
to be a career coach one
day for data scientists,
I think he'd be very successful.
[LAUGHS] Thank you, Javier.
But of on that
topic, I know you
have served as an advocate for
minority groups in AI and tech.
And I was curious
if that is something
that you do for people to
help bring them into the space
as well.
And if you have maybe
some ideas for all of us
about how we could
get more involved too.
Yeah.
I think it's, diversity is
very important in any space.
But data scientist is
definitely super important
because we build the
future for companies.
Where we build the
new capabilities.
We are truly the future of how
we're going to do business.
And by diversity, it doesn't
only means a color, race,
ethnicity, gender.
It can also be
diversity of background,
experiences, expertises that
you bring to the company.
So we have the chief
advocate for the Latino group
here at Nationwide.
And our executive
sponsor is the president
of the one of the
biggest business unit.
And he said, diversity is
not only the right thing
to do, but a good
business decision.
And what that means is, you
think about the demographic
in US.
I might get this a
little slightly wrong.
But 60% of the
population are Black
and they have a $1.8
trillion purchasing power.
And Latinos are close to
20% with another close to $2
trillion purchasing power.
And you think about a
woman, half the population,
a big group are growing and
getting more into business
and increasing the
purchasing power.
So it's a lot of money
there that if you
don't tap into that, if
you don't build solutions,
products for those individual--
and they think different.
There's no right or wrong.
But every group they have
their specific needs,
their specific characteristic.
And you need to
understand those so you
can tailor your product,
your solution for them,
and they can-- and they feel
good about buying your product
because they feel like
you care about them.
You are socially responsible.
And you support their groups.
And there's no other way
to build those products
than having the people that
understand those individual.
So if you are a data
scientist, if you
don't have think about a group
that doesn't have any minority
groups, white males, all--
nothing bad, white
males are amazing.
But think about, there's
no diversity at all.
So those individual,
they're not going
to know exactly how women
think, or Latinos, or Black,
and it's going to be very hard
for them to understand nuances
and specific things that they
are very important for them.
And they're not going
to understand that maybe
language is critical.
Something Hispanic,
they're not going
to know that probably data
is biased or some of them.
People building computer
vision system that
doesn't use a balanced data
set and doesn't correctly
train the models to identify
properly Black people,
they're going to have a problem.
Or people doing
speech recognition,
building the system to
transcribe as patient to text
and doing a lot of
solution based on that.
If they don't
understand that people
might have a different accent,
different way of talking,
they're not going
to potentially use
the right data sets to
train the models right,
and therefore not working
properly for those groups.
And those groups are
going to notice that.
And they're not going
to be happy with that.
to buy your products.
There was a public
cases about that.
There's a lot of with
recruiting with Amazon
and another insurance
company with claim.
When you needed to record
a video about your claim
and what happened.
And it was biased, or
some groups, and people
didn't like that.
And they're going to--
people are very sensitive,
and they demand a lot,
especially after COVID.
So if you don't
treat them right,
they are going to--
and with social media,
things get shared very quickly.
So if you don't
treat them right,
they are not going
to buy your products.
And they're going
to switch very fast.
So again, diversity
helps with all of that.
And how you can help?
Be an ally.
If you are a leader,
hire those individuals.
You are going to have more
powerful better teams.
If you are an
individual contributor,
ask people, mentor
them, and help them.
And you will learn too.
You will learn a lot
from those interactions.
Thank you, Emi.
Andey, I see you asked
a question in the chat
a little bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in next?
Sure.
Thanks, Rachael.
Emi, can you share about
the open source R adoption
path for your team?
I have a few questions here.
So that open source R adoption.
And did you get any
resistance from IT
in supporting getting
R into production?
And if so, what
lessons can you share
about onboarding
and supporting folks
new to R and open source tools?
Yeah.
It's definitely, of
course, security and data
protection is important.
So when we have this
dedicated environment,
we call it model factory,
that is protected,
it has all the
security controls,
and we have R and Python
embedded into that.
And every time
there's a new package,
they get tested, the versions.
You cannot go and get the latest
batch or any versions that you
think is best.
We have an approved version
for each of those tools.
We, again, we test the packages.
We give our very--
we have very long--
a lengthy procedures of
how to use it, what to do,
what not to do.
And we do peer review,
when people use, again,
whatever package or
whatever code you write,
that it gets a review
by one of your peers.
And then, before
move to production,
there is another team that
implement that and validates
that you are not incurring
to any security issues,
like a credential or
managing a specific way,
you need to follow
that protocol.
There's a lot of things
I cannot share publicly.
But there's a lot of controls
around open source systems.
So I think, again,
we have a lot of--
we are big fans.
It's cheaper.
It's easier to come get the
talent knowing those tools,
and people would like
to learn those tools.
But definitely a lot of
controls to protect the data
and protect the code.
So I'm hearing,
guardrails are important.
And then, just peer support?
Yeah.
ANDEY NUNES-BREWSTER: Thank you.
Thank you.
Alan, I see you also just
asked a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
I had to walk back
over to the computer.
I'm pacing around in my office
because it's cold in here.
I'm just curious, Emi, as you
describe this great big team
of hundreds of people,
what kind of coordination
happens across those teams?
And is that a challenge for
leaders of various teams
to figure out how
to collaborate?
Do you have to have agreement
about things like architecture
or about practices and
processes and stuff?
Just wondering how you organize
across all of those people,
and to what extent
that's even critical,
or if they're
pretty independent?
Yeah.
Again, like any other
big organization,
there's different groups
and different part
of the different organization
across the company.
it's like our data
scientists are in finance,
or data people
are in technology.
You have the data architecture
team, and the security team,
and within-- even within
IT, or within finance,
you have different groups
that are in business.
So I'm not going to--
I don't want to lie.
And I don't want to ignore that
having different organizations,
different leaders creates
some difficulties.
We try to build a pot--
group of people.
So we want to make sure
that there is leadership
support for the project.
You cannot start without that.
There can be some [INAUDIBLE]
that gets done more naturally.
But you have a project.
You have the support.
You create your business case.
You get the funding.
And then you say, OK,
in order to do this,
I will need the data
scientist, the data engineer.
So a lot of this, you can--
you have support,
you have the funding.
But also say relationship
and building a network
is important.
Because you need to go with
those leaders and get buy-in.
I even though, I might hear--
I might say, hey,
my sale leader,
the head of sales
for my business unit,
it really wants to do this.
But if I go I say, you got to
help me because I'm telling you
I say so.
That commitment might
not feel that strong.
So you need to go with
them and say, hey,
we're doing this
because of this.
And what do you
think about that?
And yeah, you might
need to find the team
or get some resources for that.
But then that
convincing is important,
the why is important.
And then you go to this
other group and do the same.
And all you have these people--
one thing I like to do is--
I'm not going to
tell them what to do.
I'm going to-- I have
this philosophy that you
need to be very tied on what
is the outcome that you want,
what is the objective, and
what is that it will be needed.
So be very clear on that.
And hopefully they
truly understand that.
And you describe it but then you
wait for them to describe it.
And you reiterate until
it kind of sound--
it's clear to them.
I think that's the best way.
Repeat what we're trying to do.
And if they are still
loose or not very clear,
you got to keep that message
until they are clear.
So be tight on that.
But then be loose on that--
how they get there.
They are way smarter than me.
So I will never tell
them, use this algorithm,
or do it this way, because
that controlling is not
going to-- it will
inhibit innovation.
And they are expert.
So we loose on that.
Let them define what is done,
what is the way, the how.
The why and what is
important to be tight.
The how, they figure it out.
They are smart.
But then, be tight on the
result. Go back and be tight on
are we achieving what we want?
And be very, very specific
and simple in that metric.
I hear someone or saw
someone talking about KPI.
So I want to increase sales.
I want to reach
this market share.
I want to-- and make
that metric that
is simple to understand
for the data scientists
how to get there, but
simple for the business
to understand that we're
achieving what we committed
to do or committed to achieve.
So that, I think,
that's important for us.
So tight, loose, tight,
give them the money,
give them the
resources, give them
the people that is needed
to let them run with that.
So we started getting very big
into the project to product,
not being very specific
on the projects
and how all the waterfall
and all that, but
be more of the product.
Here is the product that we're
trying to get out of this.
And let them figure
out the details
of how to get to that product.
And use the money and
resources as they wish.
That's great.
Thank you.
I really like that description
of the articulation of where
to be really tight and focused
versus where to let people run.
And that can be really,
really successful
when you've got skilled
people and platforms to work
from that they can use well.
And you can let them
be successful in ways
that they're really,
really strong at,
and know that you're going to
get to a well defined outcome
that you're helping steer.
Yeah, I appreciate
hearing all that.
Thank you.
No, thank you.
Thanks, Alan.
I see a great conversation
in the chat around metrics,
around dashboards, a number
of things to show in them.
And I think it's Xinyi,
and sorry if I pronounced
your name incorrectly.
Would you want to jump in and
ask the question you put there?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Actually, the
question is about how
to build a story
for the C-suite.
Because actually, we
are building dashboards
that are a management system.
So the dashboard
should be fixed just
for a bunch of metrics
on that dashboard.
But when we make plan,
design the dashboard as well,
if we only put several,
maybe four or five metrics
on the top and the
table of quick contacts,
this might not be
enough for a big company
since the story might be fixed.
But sometimes, our
C-suite might want
to know other side,
or another story.
So we are thinking about to
put maybe 20 or more index
on that dashboard.
But, of course, the C-suite
will say, oh, it's too much.
We do not have time to
read all that long reports.
Yeah.
Great question.
And definitely,
storytelling is critical.
I go back to the little kids.
And you need to
speak their language.
They are not going to
speak your language.
Go back to the kids.
You need to talk to the
kid in their language.
You talk about the
Shakespearean language to a kid,
they're not going to understand
you, and they don't care.
You're going to lose them.
So listen to your leaders.
Listen to the earning
calls or whatever ways
that they present
to the organization.
Or whomever is the
leader, try to listen
to previous conversation.
And pay attention to
the words they use.
Pay attention how
they describe things.
Pay attention to the things
that they-- the metrics
that they share, or the metrics
that they talk about it.
And use those words.
Words are important.
You can say the same thing
with different words.
Or you might have the way
you describe something,
use their words.
So if you can talk about-- we
talk about the data foundation.
And but if you say
data integrity,
you might say, well,
data foundation is the same.
But if they use the
word data foundation,
use the same data foundation.
If they say sales intelligence,
you can use another word.
Use their words so
they can understand you
and keep it consistent.
If you keep changing the
words or the way they build.
Think about in the old
times or even now Google,
but think about
[INAUDIBLE] newspaper,
or the format, any website.
But think about the old
fashioned newspaper.
New York Times, they
always look the same.
They have the same structure,
the same format, the articles,
the layout is similar.
So every day you go
and read that newspaper
or your online news, it
looks the same thing.
Imagine if they will tweak
things and move things around,
you will spend a lot
of energy and time
trying to figure it out.
And that mental
thing that your brain
is taking energy to figuring out
the format and the structure.
And you don't care about that.
You want to read the news.
So New York Times,
Washington Post, they
keep the same structure.
They keep it the same.
So all your energy
is to understand
the content of the news
that you're trying to read.
So the same thing with the
storytelling and the dashboard.
Find a way that the words,
the structure, the metrics
that they use and
they're familiar with.
So they don't spend
time and energy
trying to understand your
dashboard, your story.
That's something
they are familiar.
The only thing they're
trying to understand
is the story you are telling.
The metric that you're
tracking is going this way,
is going this other way.
We might need to
take action on this.
And be very specific.
Don't say a lot of things.
Less is better.
Be clear and concise.
But be very specific on the
things that you really care.
Repeat.
Repeat throughout your session
and throughout your dashboard.
And then, and be very
specific about the action
plan, what you need about them.
And silence and
doesn't means agree.
Silence can be, I
acknowledge that.
But doesn't mean
that they agree.
So watch them, look
at their expression.
And next time you go, repeat.
And the one thing that we--
another mistake we make
is that we go back.
Let's say you presented
something last month,
and you're going this month
to present the same thing.
Recap and say, last
month we talk about this.
Now this is happening.
And now I need you to know
this or do this for us.
We need your support.
And don't go there thinking that
they remember everything that
happened last month,
they know everything
that is happening in your world,
and assuming they know that.
Because they don't.
Whatever happened last month,
they did so many things--
like the kid.
So many things has
happened in their life
that they are not
going to remember
what you talk about last time.
Don't feel offended.
It's normal.
Go back to that and say, last
time we spoke we did this.
Now we're doing this.
Now let's bring
it to the present.
Yes.
Thank you.
Yeah.
We need to do some
recaps in the system.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, Emi.
I love that.
I have a tendency
to think, oh, we're
going to remember what we
talked about last month there.
[LAUGHS] I think that I love
to stay on this topic too,
because I see, Nessa, you
had some great thoughts that
tack on to this idea as well.
I didn't know if you
wanted to jump in as well.
And I don't mean to be
putting people on the spot.
I love when people just
share ideas in the chat too.
But Marlene, feel free to
jump in with your thoughts
on the topic too.
Sorry, which
thoughts are those?
[LAUGHS]
Well, no, I just see--
I'm trying to read
at the same time
the conversation happening
in the chat around this,
like user experience
for the dashboards
and thoughts that you and Nessa
are sharing back and forth.
So just seeing if you
want to share that.
I think-- so there's
two components,
what you show and what you say.
And Emi's hitting--
I'm just so appreciating.
I think I think these things.
But hearing them out
loud from somebody else
with an organization
that has their stuff
way more together
than mine, that's
not a knock on my organization.
It's just 100 years
old, and they do things
like 100-year-old organization.
But the doing-- the saying
the things you need to say
is very important.
So Emi's hitting that
right on the head.
I struggle with I
want to do everything
and do everything well.
And I had to realize
a couple years ago,
I can't do everything well.
So I have to lean
on people to help me
with the visualization bit.
So that was the bit
I put in the chat.
So two people that
can really help you
is usually somebody in
the marketing department
who really have an eye
for user experience,
how something's laid out
visually, and how it flows.
I get that guy to look at it.
It could be a woman in your
organization or somebody
non-binary.
But the marketing
guy, the UX guy,
I ping him at least two,
three times during a project
to make sure, does this
need major overhaul?
Is this OK?
Does it get the story across?
And then I get somebody
with finance experience.
Doesn't have to be
a bigwig of finance,
even somebody who's just in
the accounting department
or finance.
They can be
different departments
in your organization.
But somebody who can see
the numbers beyond the data.
So this trend, this
upward trend, well,
what does that mean to you?
Oh, well, yeah, I
could see that we might
want to spend money there.
Or we need to cut costs there.
So if they can extrapolate that
easily from what you've done,
I think you've done
more than half the job.
The rest is just the speaking.
And then, following on, I want
to say, Emi's kind of book
of, keep it simple, stupid.
Right?
Just keep the bullet points.
Or for those of you--
I might date myself here--
Dragnet, right?
Facts, ma'am.
Just the facts.
So just giving the
facts and the takeaways,
I think, really, really helped.
So teaching a bit
of a master class
here, Emi, like a Ted Talk.
I kind of want to just bottle
you up and take you everywhere.
Thanks for your insights.
Oh, no.
Thank you.
Thank you for the kind words.
And you're right.
Nobody knows everything.
You need to check with people.
Just be careful.
Because you want
to get it perfect.
And you want to
check with everyone.
You might get a paralysis
because you're, well,
I need to check with
the user design.
I need to check with this.
I need to check-- and then
you keep checking with things
and trying to make sure
everything is perfect.
And then you never get it out.
So I used to have my--
I was an entrepreneur
for a little bit,
I had my own company.
And I think that helped.
Because when you're
an entrepreneur,
you don't have money.
You need to get things out
and start making money.
So that pushed you to, well,
I need to get something out.
I can bring the income.
So think about the same as a
data person, a data scientist,
you want to get something
out to start producing
money for the company.
You're going to make it better.
But you need to have the due
diligence in terms of security
and accuracy and all that.
But think about, yeah, you
don't want to rush things,
it's too much.
But you got to get the money.
So check with people.
Make sure that everybody
thinks the same.
But keep it moving.
Prototype it, get it out,
ask for some feedback,
and keep making it better.
Thank you.
AJ, I see you had asked
a question earlier
on different tools.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
I was just curious though,
for your development process,
whether you use a
traditional common bond
way of producing content,
such as analytics dashboard,
or you follow all
agile approach, where
you treat one dashboard
as its own digital product
and continuously every PI,
make improvements to it?
Because I've seen
both in the past.
They have their pros and cons.
I was just curious if
you had opinions on what
one works better than the other?
Yeah.
I think it's, at one point
we tried to go a full agile
and follow all the
methodologies used by IT.
I don't think that was the best.
I think it has to be--
we follow a [INAUDIBLE]
DM methodology.
And but we realized that data
scientists and the teams,
they don't like the daily
standards and the full agile
concept.
They need time to sit
down, think through
the problem, work on that.
And so, we give them that space
so they can focus and spend
quality time on the project.
We try not to bug you
a lot and protect them.
So it's, again, [INAUDIBLE]
DM, a little bit of DevOps.
Of course, when we implement the
solution, we work with type DM,
we follow their methodologies,
their agile, DevOps,
and all that.
We use DataOps.
We started implementing
DataOps for the data part.
And now we have MLOps for
all the model monitoring
once it's in production.
So I think I will go with
this, building those parts,
and giving them the
freedom to work together.
And that has proven
to be the best.
Don't try to go all
in with the agile
and in traditional
IT technologies.
Of course, the things that
probably they hate the most
is all the waterfall and
PowerPoint status updates
and things like that.
They really don't like that.
Of course, we need to share
with management updates
and know what's going on.
But we don't force
them, or we don't
make them build this beautiful
PowerPoint presentation to keep
management happy.
It's a lot of--
part of my job is
trying to protect them to give
them the freedom and the time
to focus on what they do
best that is not PowerPoints,
or having stand-ups
and things like that.
But to sit down and
build algorithms.
Thank you.
I see you have a fellow
Nationwider on the call
too, Francisco, do you want
to jump in with your question?
Yeah.
Can you hear me OK?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yes.
EMI ZAMBADA: Yeah.
All right.
Hi, Emi.
My question was just
basic general advice
for transitioning
into a data science
and analytics-focused role,
specifically for someone
coming from somewhere else.
Personally, in my
experience, I'm going--
I actually just found out
I'm moving towards that data
and analytics role in a recent
team shift where I'm coming
from operational support.
And I don't really
have much experience
within analytics
and data science
studying operations in college,
where my internships were
mostly focused on that.
So I was wondering,
from your perspective
as a leader, what advice and
insight do you have for someone
who is brand new, like myself?
Yeah.
Don't try to be a data
scientist from scratch.
It requires a lot of
expertise, a lot of knowledge,
and experience, and education.
A lot of people they go
and take an online course,
which is great.
Or they build up a
little toy project,
and they want to go
into data scientist,
and they don't get the job,
and they get frustrated.
So start with something
data analytics,
start with something
business intelligence,
supporting an area with some
dashboard, some analysis,
even if it's an Excel.
Build those projects
that get you started.
And then think about,
how much passion,
or where do you want to go?
If I think about myself, I was
passionate about the topic.
I've been learning, always
trying to learn new things.
But I knew myself
that I would not
be able to compete with the data
scientists, people that have
PhDs, they're mathematicians.
They're really good
at what they do.
If I would have gone
into that track,
I would probably
have failed and not
be as competitive and
as good as they are.
But then I thought
about, well, what
are the things that I think
I do best and the things
that-- it's like you
have a new product.
You go back to being
an entrepreneur.
You are your own product.
You are your own brand.
And think about it, you
will go in the market
and compete versus
Apple with the iPhone.
You are not going to
make a good deal there.
You are not going to be
able to beat the Apple
and be better that--
build something better
than the iPhone.
So instead of that say,
but what is the guy-- what
is that thing that is missing?
And then they will
say, oh, well,
there's not an app
for to do this.
Then build that app that
will make an iPhone better.
So think about that
in your organization
or in the industry.
And what is that data scientist?
Yeah, we'll never have enough.
But there are a lot of
good people, very smart.
But maybe think about,
maybe in my organization,
there are not a lot of
very good data engineers.
And I like that.
Maybe start being
a data engineer,
because there is the need.
There is the market need.
Again, be yourself
a brand, a product.
And I don't mean
it in a bad way.
But be-- fill that need,
understand that need,
and try to fulfill that need.
And then continue
learning and continue
filling out what is your career
and where do you want to go.
So I hope that helps.
Continue learning.
Don't get desperate.
But don't try to get
pushed to something
that might not fit with
your career progression
or what you can really
do in the short-term,
and not get frustrated.
There will be someone or a
position that might help you.
Yes.
Thank you so much.
I think on this topic as well,
there is a kind of related.
There was a Slido question.
Is there anything that
you or your company
looks for in new
data science hires,
so on both the technical
and soft skills?
Yeah.
And I put it on the
chat, my LinkedIn,
if anyone wants to
connect, happy to do so.
I think there's
definitely the demand,
the technical
expertise, the coding.
But being very analytical,
like asking questions,
be someone that cares
about the business,
someone that is passionate about
that, that asks good questions,
think through problem-solving,
think about the problems,
and what is the thing that
we really need to solve.
So I think it's a combination.
And some people are better with
one thing, better at the other.
So try to fit,
again, your profile
to whatever the
spectrum that can be.
If you are very into the
technical thing, the math,
you can do that.
But if you are more on the
analytical or the business
translator, do that.
But we are very rigorous
into data scientists.
And we have a very
strict hiring process.
So that involves a lot of
the technical expertise.
And depending on if
you send [INAUDIBLE]
vision, whatever that might
be, we have a specific process.
But again, don't
feel discouraged
if you don't have all of that.
Maybe find that role
that fit you need.
Thank you.
I know we just hit
the top of the hour,
and a few people have to drop.
And I want to make sure,
do you have a meeting
you're running to, Emi?
I don't, but I need to
disconnect here quickly.
So I don't know if any
last questions, comments?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: There was
only one last question,
if that's OK.
One that we had missed.
And thank you for sharing
your LinkedIn there
for people to connect
and follow-up as well.
But the question was, with
so many data scientists,
I assume a poly-lingual team.
And you talked about all the
different languages people use.
How have you navigated the R
Python dichotomy, especially
with respect to
deployment solutions?
Yeah.
Our model factory
environment is suited
for both and other languages.
So everything we build, try
to be flexible with whatever
programming language is used.
Basically, R and Python.
There's people that are
experts in R, others in Python.
But a lot of that,
as an insurance
company, financial services,
we're very heavy on R.
But it's transitioning,
probably 70, 80, 20,
I think we're 50/50 but
moving towards Python.
So people are trying
to learn both.
And they proven to be more
successful if they know both.
So not easy and difficult
to have expectation
to be an expert on both.
But if you feel
expertise in one,
but then know how to do a little
basic on the other language,
that can be extremely powerful.
Thank you so much.
I think we got to
everybody's questions.
I'm sorry if there was
anything that we missed.
But thank you all
so much for joining.
Thank you, Emi, for all
your great insights.
This was great.
And I see-- if
you can't see now,
there's a lot of people
in the chat saying
thank you right now as well.
Thank you all for joining.
And I appreciate the time.
And happy to connect.
And let me know if there's
anything I can do to help you.
Thanks, Rachael, for having me.
Enjoy Florida over there.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.